people of the internets hello and
welcome back to harry potter and the
chamber of secrets if you remember last
time we left off
just getting out of borgin and berks we
had just escaped guys and i think we're
out of nocturne alley
all together so that's what we're gonna
pick up this time i'm just gonna head on
out of here
and i think i i hear it sounds like
friendly voices wait
morriben's closed you can try to open
the door though
interesting very interesting okay what
about this
oh same place so for meeting for the
first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell we post videos
every week here on youtube
and right now i'm just gonna go talk to
this witch over here hello favorite
lockhart book
is voyages with vampires yes i remember
that one with trolls is also very good
indeed indeed okay all right let's make
our way out of here
all right cutscene time hurry
harry we hoped you'd only gone one fair
place too far
i was frantic with ah that's okay mrs
weasley what's wrong ginny
you don't look very happy whoa look at
that witch in the background what's
going on
what's going on with her head right
there she has like no neck
let's go look for them that's so kind of
you harry but i think you'll need to get
your things first
what was on your school list a
well let's all go to flourish and blocks
then oh and you might need this
it fell into the heart when you use the
skull let's go
thanks mrs wheezing it's our first
sickle come on harry
let's go to flourish i do have a
question though i do have a question
harry you know the weasleys don't have a
lot of money
and you have a little fortune over there
in in gringotts so
why are you taking the weasley's money
harry come on man
one sickle all right let's do this dude
see as a kid i i never tried to explore
all of this
but now i'm gonna try and explore i'm
gonna see like
where will the game not let me go madame
malkin's robes for all occasions come on
why are they closed
there's no there's no reason they should
be closed same store right there
all right what if i go over here is
something gonna force me back
any birdie bot beans here oh a little
advertisement here looks like a
broomstick there
and goodness gracious what is that on
the right side
some kind of creepy teddy bear
monokuma any danganronpa fans out there
anybody anybody
all right so let's talk to you lockhart
is a five-time winner of witch weekly's
most charming smile award
and when you meet him face to face you
can see all right so
everybody's freaking out about gilderoy
lockhart because he is
in town today this gringotts right here
can we go in there no of course not
of course not i can't go get my own
money i have to take the weasley's
money instead all right that's fine fine
we'll go on around
look at this hello sir how are you
professor quirrell is that you
no definitely not how about you who are
you
oh i can't talk to you come on
somebody in the comments on the last
video was talking about just how good
the graphics are for
for when this game released and i i
agree i have to agree i i think the art
style is great
a big jump over the pc version from
sorcerer's stone
and i don't know what chamber i think
chamber of secrets on the pc was in the
same style
as the sorcerer's stone pc
version so i don't think it looked it
wasn't quite in the same art style i
don't think they started
basically doing the same games until
later
excuse me excuse me
can i just grab this hopefully wizard
card and leave
you're feeding the stock
excuse me what's going on here sir
well we can't just leave i mean we're
harry potter we've got to investigate
this situation right
whoops can i hop over
what is going on back there the music
got all creepy
i don't like that dude's voice okay can
we make out what is on this certificate
right here
this is to certify
oh man it would take me forever to read
this because of how
how blurry it is this is the certified
that is
nothing i'll let you guys if you're that
curious you could pause the video
you guys can tell me down in the
comments later what exactly that says
what is going on over here
okay i guess i don't have to be in here
all right well try to remember or i will
try to remember
oh the ice cream parlors closed no way
quality quidditch supplies of course
they're closed as well
why is everybody closed gambling japes
all right
can we go in there
[Music]
you know they just like oh this one's
open let's go
let's go all right gamble and james what
do you guys got going on in here
oh i didn't try this in that other shop
the magical menagerie
i might need to go back and try lumos
hello sir how much are stink pellets
full sickles
repetition darn it i only have one
sickle i
can't afford that do you know who i am
sir
no harry wouldn't do that harry wouldn't
do that we can't pull that one guys
that's a malfoy move it's not it's not a
harry potter move right there
can i go in can i go around back
he's cool with it all right wow what is
going on back here dude
see this can reveal hidden paths so i
i forgot back there i should have tried
it in the other store oh
that definitely looks like a spot that i
should be able to sneak into
[Music]
oh so close i think we might have to
like upgrade the spell or something
because remember when we were at the
weasleys they're like yeah that's not no
way through
yeah you don't have enough power harry
for it to hit the top
okay so another mental note we need to
come back in here as well
if we ever get that spell powered up and
the crazy thing is guys yes i played
this game before it's amazing how much
you forget though it's been so many
years and i played through this one
multiple times multiple times
all right let's go back outside
all right so mental note to go back in
there
as well anything over here nope that's
wizarding equipment wise acres whisker
i think it's i think it's wise acre
probably way wrong but
dude sirius black a year early
no no i don't think so all right what's
over here
quality quidditch supplies okay oh wait
we're just going backwards going the
wrong way i told you guys in
in past let's plays i am so bad with
directions
it's really bad man it's really really
bad
all ups all emporium of course is closed
the spell flourishing bloods alright i
think this is where we need to be
you look like you've forgotten something
harry oh they remember all that's right
yes mrs lee okay what have i forgotten
mrs weasley
where's the remember all uh bystander
book
oh yeah flourishing bots all right we're
getting to it we're getting to it
we're just exploring just checking out
what's in the area here
now if i buy this i wonder if i'll be
able to upgrade flopindo right away
hello sir how much is this book the
standard book of spells grade two by
miranda
gospal oh now that would be one second
well
look at that how can i buy that please
how convenient for me mrs weasley gave
me one signal
with the knowledge contained in this
book you'll be able to cast more
powerful spells here's a helpful hint
from the book
there we go build up the power on your
wand
and cast it when the special is ready
but be careful
don't overpower yourself oh i do
remember
if you hold it down too long then it
like backfires on you
okay it pays to increase your spell
power in the first volume of this series
readers were instructed on how to
perform the most basic spells
volume 2 demonstrates techniques
enabling the advanced student
yeah basically what he just told us if
you release the spell button at the
right time you will perform a
perfect cast the most powerful
version of the spell careful not to hold
too long yeah
students are encouraged to experiment
all right
lapses can result in painful side
effects
okay so am i like instantly powered up
like just by reading that am i good to
go now
there's coughing back there
anything else i need to find in here
oops i'm gonna check here and make sure
that there's nothing
do i need to like oh here it is okay
i don't need to do anything else all
right yeah cause
actually wait that's my first spell book
okay just making sure there's not
anything else we needed to do
gilderoy lockhart's are fascinating
too so good-looking okay all right okay
then
flourishing blocks all right goodbye got
what we needed
now i want to go back to gamble and
japes see if we're powered up enough to
to cast a more powerful flapindo spell
well harry did you get your book yes yes
ready to go
i can't wait to try out what i've
learned where did you lose your things
ginny
i think i dropped my bra scales when i
passed the fireplace
[Music]
in shapes leaky cauldrons two of the
three places that i've already been to
it is so kind of you to do this oh jimmy
no problem at all
no problem thanks so much i got you
jenny i got it
show us what you can do with your new
spells bet you can smash those barrels
so we are powered up already we don't
have to do anything else
wait what barrels those barrels right
there i mean right right in front of
these people
but underage wizards aren't allowed to
use magic outside of school
oh and there's sickles inside let's go
all right two sickles two sickles and a
dunk bomb
my lucky day who understood that
reference
who understood that reference if you
understood that reference let me know
in the chat if you didn't then you're
not a true harry potter fan i'm kidding
i'm kidding
it is a i'll give you guys a hint if you
if you didn't understand that reference
it is from a
an old school harry potter youtube video
from way back in the day let's go ahead
and save right here
what in the world
all right so let's go back to gamble and
japes first
which is down here
so it's part we have to go back there
it's not an optional area we definitely
need to go back in there
all right so we're back in the magical
menagerie and we've got this message
here if you want to get the magical
measure to the top
you'll need to cast a perfect flipping
spell on it to do that build up the
power on your wand for as long as you
dare
and then cast the spell just before it
overpowers
all right so this is kind of like a good
practice spot for us all right
wait what wait what my one's red
did it not work
there we go so the first time i think i
held it just a little bit too long but
it wasn't long enough for it to backfire
on me
but it's going on right there oh that's
jenny's quill
oh are there sickles in all of these
i know we got to destroy all of them
then can i lock on to these
no dude i almost
missed that right there did you guys
love in
in part one when i
what
it's like what is this a mimic chest got
dark souls on us all of a sudden
no just a chocolate frog
but yeah in the in part one of this
harry potter in the chamber secret
series
right as i'm talking about oh i'm a
completionist guys
i like to i like to find everything i
just walk
right by a chest man right by a chest
all right well the good news is we are
up to nine sickles now we found jenny's
quill
anything that i need to do with this can
i like break that
no okay all right we're gonna use lumos
to make sure there's not like some
special hidden area in here
all right doesn't look like it so let's
make our way oh can i not go through
there
come on let me through let me through i
want to see what's behind this
door all right we're just going to crawl
on back and then we need to head back
over
to
the other shop which name i'm all of a
sudden forgetting
magical menagerie that's it
oh i could buy some of these now
how many sickles were they again full
sickles
oh four sickles for a pack of ten some
stink pellets let's do it man
give me some stink pellets you now have
some stink pellets these can be equipped
from the inventory and remember all as
you would a spell to throw a sink pellet
press the appropriate button
apart from being great fun stink pellets
can be used to stun
small magical creatures or to get you
out of a sticky situation
with prefix oh dude all right let's go
ahead and i'm going to apply those right
now you can hold up to
15 it looks like no didn't mean to do
that
all right there we go so we'll put those
on the b button right now
okay magical menagerie
we're gonna find out what's going on in
here but what i don't understand is like
how does powering up the spell
i don't know how that's going to help me
maybe there's a oh wait those barrels
were blocking the way
right okay feeding the stock
out he's still telling me to keep out
but you know what dude
no can do my man no can do one sickle
come on
i don't know why everybody's keeping
sickles in these barrels but
what is going on in this place man
didn't you hear me boy i said we're
closed now sticks
there's a switch over there by him a
button that we need to press
okay
come on the game like beating you over
the head
oh look at this what is this here
nah i know it's it was a game made for
kids might distract him
ah or we did just buy these stink
pellets wait what is this weird
camera view going on here oh i need a
wall okay i need to wall sneak i think
yeah remember we can do this
dude this camera view is oh no
go check it out over here
if i didn't have this annoying camera
view to work with
i can't even see him nasty
fire crap needs unblocking
i just want to see find jenny spello
tape in the leaky cauldron
by potion vial from mole peppers
apothecary
find ginny scales okay that's what i'm
looking for here in the magical
menagerie
like why can't i just tell this dude be
like yo i wonder if the noise of a spell
might distract him okay the reason that
the camera is is reversed
camera control yeah the camera is so
weird right now
like
yeah that's not distracting him at all
harry
oh geez he's coming
if i can just stay out of his way
is that all it takes harry no dude he's
like
okay there we go we finally got his
attention but the only problem is he's
gonna go
right back where we need to be
i know you're here i'm careful i should
be able to creep past him yeah come over
here dude
nasty go right go right
no no come on
maybe i need to cast like a super
powerful one
i wonder if the noise yeah i wonder too
harry
all right go do it
if i'm careful i should be able to creep
past him
i'm running i'm running oh jeez
oh my goodness the camera was so bad
right there
the camera was so bad
wizard card though for our efforts let's
go
let's go
who do we have here tilly toke gained
order of
merlin first class for saving the lives
of non-magical
tourists during a ill-filfried comb
incident of 1932 when a dragon swooped
down on a beach
full of sunbathers 1903-19
all right chili toke there we go
and it looks like there's jenny scales
anything else i can do in here
do you have a secret entrance or exit
oh don't tell me i gotta sneak by this
guy again
no i just wanna leave
he's gonna be standing right there watch
oh he's right he is right there oh my
gosh
okay he's coming back over there let's
get out of here dude
that is me running out of your shop
later
all right we got that one taken care of
so let's take a look
at what our i think we still have two
objectives left
we need jenny's fellow tape in the leaky
cauldron and buy a potion vial
from mole peppers apothecary
let's see if any of these are labeled on
the map
[Music]
what they've got a that's great i mean i
knew they had the map but then they
actually
you can go into each shop has its own
map
that's crazy dude
all right i don't see one for the leaky
cauldron though so it's only places that
you've already been to
i'm guessing on this page right here
that the stars there's
five total stars so they almost
certainly mark the places that
i've already been to
wallpapers apothecary don't we need
something in here
pretty sure we need something in here
yep the potion vial
okay hopefully we have enough sickles to
buy the potion vial
whoa there's a lot going on in here
what i want the chocolate frog
can i lock on that one what's in there
oh i missed it though
darn it nothing was in that one
all right sir i would like to buy this
potion vial this is potion vial
it costs eight circles no
do you have any barrels sir
do you have any barrels with sickles
inside
how about these can i destroy these oh
my goodness you guys
i gotta have to find some more sickles
he locked it on his okay well
all right we gotta go find some more
barrels to destroy
i wonder if the barrels respawn because
if they respawn
that would make it a lot easier
let's see actually no looks like they
don't
okay is this the leaky cauldron though
yeah let's go ahead and do the spellow
tape
well look who it is guys rubius hagrid
hello hagrid i tell you i've been having
a bit of trouble lately with
flesh-eating slugs
the leaky cauldron's the finest pub in
london harry ernie
a huge seller you know i see him really
miss norbert
people think about him almost every day
how many lines of dialogue does he have
that's three
i saw mrs weasley looking for you or
i've been creeping around that knock
turn alley
terrible place you'd best stay away okay
did i
tell you i've been having a bit all
right there we go that's pretty good
though i mean
like four dialogue options there's more
than butterbeer down in the center
well appreciate that hint sir
oh this kill two birds with one stone
here get enough sickles
and we're gonna find jenny's spello tape
oh okay
okay all right
oh bernie bob beans birdie bop beans
just three okay
another birdie pop bean not only do they
store
sickles in the barrels you can also find
birdy bop beans in them as
well
there we go lock that up yes
now when we get back up there we'll be
able to pass across no problem
the question is what will we have to go
through to get there
blast ended scroots are you
kidding me right now
all right oh no dude
oh just nothing a little flapindo can't
help with
can i like run up and kick him now
like mario koopa troopas you know
i don't think they're gonna stay that
way for long though
i'm afraid when i turn around they're
gonna be like right there
no oh my goodness he took so many beans
yeah the camera is really really not
good at times in this
and like sometimes it just doesn't give
me the freedom to really move it around
is that a trap as i walk over it to test
it
anything hidden in here all right
what in the world what is
this
john perry there we go
all right i need some dirty bot beans
there we go to make up for those that i
lost
a pumpkin pastry
still don't know why they don't call it
pumpkin pasty
but whatever whatever goodness
dude ernie needs to fix this place up
wait it's not ernie it's tom ernie's the
night bus driver right
you guys have already commented haven't
you you already commented when i messed
up the first time
i was thinking i was like ernie prang
but he's the he's the night bus driver
tom the bar man for leaky cauldron
it's been a while chad relax
i'll catch up don't worry
see i still say chat sometimes like i'm
like i'm streaming this live
but i'm talking to youtube the youtube
comments just it says weird it would
sound too weird if i'm like
hey comments this is what i mean
okay let's push this off
all right and then i guess we're gonna
have to push the barrel over
so do i just hop down now oh
all right harry hope you've been working
out this summer
there we go nice work even though you
did learn when guardium leviosa
last school year we're not going to work
we're not going to worry about that
right now
no come on
get up there okay why didn't he grab the
birdie bop bean
it's going to disappear just in time
just in the nick of time all right
that's it for the birdie bop beans
what in the world
oh yeah oh yeah we got this
tom dude what is going on down in your
basement man
what is going on in the basement tom
family spirits are available strong
cordial three sickles
man just like this place is so cool
they really did a great job i mean i
know it's small but
this giant cauldron over here wait
what's this one say
same thing on those signs right there
all right yeah thanks for nothing guys
just leaving me down there all right now
we've got jenny spello tape
now we've got more sickles we should be
able to go
and buy the vial now
all right so now we need wait what harry
no all your things jenny we've got one
more thing to do guys
gotta go buy the file you're so
wonderful
no really you're just so you are such a
kind boy harry
here have a chocolate frog for your egg
thank you mrs weasley
thanks mrs williams to have a wizard
card but okay chocolate for all good too
because of his latest book in flourish
and blocks
we were thinking of going in no i need
to go buy a phone i have to come with us
harry
oh uh well
okay then he really does not want to go
he really has no desire i don't blame
you harry
oh good okay it's still gonna let me
still gonna let me free roam around a
little bit
until i'm ready buy potion vial from all
pepper spots carry yeah that's what we
need to do
all right so we need to go back down
is this it now this is the quidditch
supply
ice cream parlor that's the magical
menagerie here we go mall peppers
all right i don't know why you're
selling these things for eight sickles
dude
how much is this part but i'm back it
costs eight sickles
and i've got enough i'd like to buy that
please
thank you you're very welcome to fill
your potion file
with queen world stamina
over there to fill your wicked weld file
stand by the cauldron and press
a when harry is low on stamina he will
automatically okay that's cool
so kind of like a legend of zelda fairy
good to have though glad we went and got
the file all your vials are now full
okay so we only have
that implies though that you can get
more than one vial
yep there we go no
i keep pushing the wrong button to back
out of here
you have to push z again which feels so
weird
all right now we can go and meet
gilderoy
lockhart okay back to flourishing blots
we go hey there he is
no surely not it is you're harry
potter
yep the scars here the scars here
ladies and gentlemen this is the perfect
moment for me
still what are you doing here
announcement i accept mouthful
announcing that this term i will be
taking up the post of defense against
the dark arts
teacher there's a lot of people coughing
in this game
[Applause]
oh goodness we just get the applause
even though nobody's here
didn't you potter famous harry potter
can't even go into a book shop without
making the front page so hard not to
quote all this
he didn't want all that potter's got a
girlfriend
i suppose your parents would go hungry
for a month to pay for all the books
dude
[Music]
let me give you some coaching harry fame
is a fickle friend and i would encourage
you to be careful how you play the same
game
so to speak be sparing with your public
appearances at first
and watch the company you keep harry why
i remember the time
actually actually some good advice hurry
we've missed the train
i believe the more exposure i got in the
press my career would progress
miss the truth what else missed the
train
yes the hogwarts express left five
minutes ago
no no i went mysteriously missing for
three weeks oh no
what are we going to do subsequently
leaking the story to the prophet
mrs weasley like really messing up here
really messing up not getting us to the
train on time
okay it's our only chance you haven't
read the books or seen the movies
and some reason you're watching this
video that is not how it happens
not how it happened in the book or the
movie yeah you you should probably leave
two lock art if you're teaching there
this year
all right guys that's gonna be a good
place to stop for this video thank you
all so much for watching if you enjoyed
this make sure to give it a thumbs up
before you go
as always thank you so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon